welcome back to Washington Journal as
you notice that last footage of course
of the Iwo Jima memorial which is near
Arlington National Cemetery we'll be
seeing other scenes from a cemetery in
our coverage of Veterans Day right here
on c-span Camille Poly's professor and
author thanks very much for joining us
this morning nice to be here again on
Veterans Day you've chosen a couple of
articles that caught your attention in
the papers this morning including this
one from USA Today as post Liu's vets
younger ones aren't taking their places
why did this catch her attention
well I'm very concerned as a career
teacher about the the lack of not only
respect for the military in the arts
community but of the lack of contact of
our students with urgent questions of
military preparedness I feel that
military history is a should be a very
important part of basic education at the
both the primary school level and the
college level it's particularly
important for anyone who hopes to
through positions of leadership in
politics we've seen the disaster I voted
for Clinton twice I'm a Democrat but the
the lack of of the sense of the
geopolitical stage in the Clinton
administration the / concern with
domestic issues for so long until we're
plummeted by crises into decisions that
I very much regret the the use of the
military for for wasteful peacekeeping
missions the over reliance on on bombing
for for purposes of intimidation all
these things I think must be dealt with
by early education in military crisis
management and just a kind of analysis
of the other techniques of military
strategy the brilliant techniques that
have come down to us through history
where do you think that education might
take place I do feel on the primary
level I think there has been a terrible
neglect of basic historical training
there has I haven't although I'm a
libertarian I happen to agree with a
conservative critics of the educational
system our our kids are coming out of
primary school at high school with a
kind of parochialism provincialism
without a sense of until the movies the
Steven Spielberg's movie
and began to dramatize the the
tremendous sacrifices made by young men
in history to preserve our liberties in
particular the great achievement of
world war ii and in defeating hitler if
America had not intervened Hitler would
have gone on to demolish England and
rule the world we invite you to join us
this morning with your questions and
comments and newspaper articles if you
have them our guest at Camille Polya a
professor and author professor of
humanities at the University of the Arts
in Philadelphia is an online columnist
for Salon magazine and the author of
several books hometown as Endicott New
York you've probably seen her a number
of speeches and panels which she's
participated in which you've seen here
on c-span with us for about 45 minutes
or so 202 is the area code six to four
eleven eleven for liberals for
conservatives six to four eleven fifteen
and seven thirty seven six seven three
four four moderates another article at
cuts ride this morning Wall Street
Journal theater Shakespeare on the pier
new Chicago Shakespeare Theater kicks
off its first season with Anthony and
Cleopatra I'm delighted to see this
article Antony and Cleopatra is my
favorite Shakespeare play I'm currently
teaching my Shakespeare course at the
University of the Arts and in
Philadelphia the play has so much in it
I think as a kind of lesson keep
carrying forward our military theme here
Cleopatra one of them one of our few
examples of an important female leader
in history and the disaster that she
brought upon her nation and upon her
aligns with Mark Antony through her lack
of metallic military preparedness at the
great Battle of Actium she made certain
key decisions that were or poor one's
forcing Antony to or having to persuade
Antony to fight by sea when his when his
experience had been as as an army leader
on the land it's a great lesson our
women who want to get into the Oval
Office have got to realize that they
will never convince the American people
that we can have a female
commander-in-chief until they can
demonstrate that that that women are
capable of more than mere compassionate
caretaking issues that they have a
feeling for for the hard decisions a
military leader must make to send people
to die in war
and also a keen sense of the kind of
battle plans that are necessary the
efficient use of military force at at
crisis moments you mentioned women in
the Oval Office who on today's political
scene do you see as possibly being in
the Oval Office well I I was
disappointed with the way Elizabeth Dole
had conducted her her potential
candidacy I felt that that her persona
was a little bit too much on the kind of
sweet and compassionate aside coming
from her presidency as a head of the
American Red Cross
I like Dianne Feinstein very much the
senator from California she has
extensive foreign relations experience
and I think that the person who is
really ready right now is governor
christine Todd Whitman of of New Jersey
again and again I've seen her in the
media becoming it with a kind of
commanding posture and manner and yet
she has the the smile the cordiality of
that distinguishes female politicians I
think she actually Whitman is the best
shot for the first female president one
of the reasons we have you here this
morning is you were in town last night
speaking at the Smithsonian on what
subject well the Herschel Museum of the
Smithsonian as a giant exhibition on
beauty the question of beauty and
aesthetics is returning to education
after this long PC period where there
was a polarization of culture and every
level and art was reduced to mere
contents of a particularly tedious and
they now an uploaded liberal kind and I
lectured on my interpretation of beauty
it was a huge slide lecture that began
in the Stone Age moved through Greek
antiquity sort down to the to the
Renaissance and finally to modern
popular culture I think that our arts
education is another thing that is
desperately needed in our our public
schools I've been an outspoken critic of
the NEA and the way conducted itself as
I've been teaching most of my career in
arts colleges I'm very concerned with
the education of artists as well as as
the cultivation of the mass audience and
the NEA behaved in to me a deplorable a
politicized way
it wasn't indeed become a tool of an
elitist limousine liberal set I'm not
surprised that Congress is so is so
chary about funding it and what we need
is a massive renaissance of arts
education that would demonstrate to the
to to our people at large and to
Congress that without art a culture
turns into a kind of province it turns
into a mere fills into Phil's to nism
when we finally go into outer space and
meet presumably other intelligent
civilizations we will represent
ourselves as a species by our arch and
right now I fear art making as well as
appreciation of art in the pits little
more than half an hour with Camila Polly
a professor and author independence
Kansas on the moderate line good morning
good morning years ago they had what
they called ROTC programs in this
schools and this was an introduction to
the young people on military and it was
a voluntary thing I don't know whether
they still have it or not
and it's not why don't they and could it
be instituted again thank you I fear
that my generation of the 1960s because
of protests against the Vietnamese war
really reduced the prestige of these
ROTC programs there were all kinds of
demonstrations outside the offices and
training centers on campus I think that
that we definitely do need to revitalize
the the idea of military service and to
into it to encourage our young men to to
enter such groups instead of for example
shooting up their high schools with
automatic weapons Charleston South
Carolina good morning good morning I was
just reading an article I had just
finished reading the article by Thomas
soul and the Post and Courier down here
this morning on the education system
takes prize
or excuse making Thomas all as usual
breaks a very good article and he does
point out the fact that the teachers
seem to want to blame the parents they
want to blame society they want to blame
everybody other than themselves for the
disastrous position that our educational
system is and today thank you
well part of the problem is and since my
generation of the 1960s went through
education has been turned into therapy
that was self-esteem is supposed to be
the aim of education I don't I don't
believe that's the case I benefited as
did my mother who came from Italy at the
age of six from a superb rigorous
disciplined public education system that
was intent on Americanizing our
disparate ethnicities and and education
was once a true door into opportunity
the the level of the quality of
instruction has has certainly plummeted
there are some fine suburban high
schools but the the inner cities are
absolute sewers it is a national scandal
that we've abandoned the inner city
schools that the true affirmative action
would be for from a massive you know
help really it kind of was like four and
eight at this point to the the condition
of the schools I spoken on my column and
salon magazine about the terrible waste
of dropping bombs on Iraq or an Kosovo
when social services are are also
neglected in the inner cities and
particularly education Boston good
morning good morning sir I've just got a
quick question here from mr. Paglia I
did hear a couple comments you have
pertaining to the military and also to
young teenagers being more Herrin to at
the military I myself am 23 years old I
just got out there for years duty in the
Marine Corps infantry and I think the
one thing that really is not attracting
more kids to the military is the reason
that does that that much educational
benefits available me myself
going to college right now the VA really
doesn't offer that much money for you
just to pay for school these days
because with the rising costs and
everything so I think more kids are
really trying to stay away from the
military right now I'm trying to pursue
a more professional career didn't Ashley
Trump trying to go into the military
just basically just get dirty and try to
have some fun with you Thank You Boston
well I'm sorry to hear what you're
saying I do think they should be more
incentives to join the military my
family
the military has very high prestige my
father and all my uncles
served in World War two they I I just my
father was able to go to college the
first and family of 10 because of the GI
Bill he was able to study abroad because
of the GI Bill I think that this is
something we've because we've been in
generally a peacetime period we have
this declining sense of national support
to to the military we're going to pay
the price for this the the world is a
dangerous place eventually by the
eternal cyclical law of history there
will be war again and I'm very concerned
about about even the the readiness of
our military because of gender games
being played by the by the political
establishment in Washington trying to
use the the military as a laboratory for
social engineering a kind of hurry up
equality between the sexes in ways that
may indeed have have been dilatory us to
basic training camille Polya writes a
column for the online magazine salon
this is the column from October 27th
under the headline Feinstein for
President Buchanan for Emperor
Dianne's no flibbertigibbet Hillary's
Eagle um fur rush has tremendous
intellectual influence and Hesh is a
pancake brain and italian-american women
rocket like they talk it what all did
you write about in this column well
number one I think Rush Limbaugh is a
huge influence on the mass audience I
have been at war with a
Snooky liberals on this question I enjoy
listening to his show whenever I can I
do have the teacher turned during the
day but when I'm in the car and listen
to him I find his find his his know his
manner of expression but his the
deafness with which he analyzes
contemporary issue is very inspiring
I think the contempt for him by liberals
is contemptible other issues there I
think that I hope that pep you can has
not gone off the deep end
I'm very unsettled by certain quasi
fascist elements and in his appeal I
think he's an intelligent man but I
don't want a politician to be a cult of
one and other issues there that you
mentioned about italian-american women
rocket rocket yes that's right
I Italian American women have not really
made enormous contributions to
contemporary culture we have a lot of
italian-american men and in the
performing arts I'm I'm on the warpath
about what I feel are there's a kind of
policy of almost ethnic disparagement of
Italian Americans in the media in ways
that would never be tolerated about
african-americans or or about Jews I'm a
great admirer of the Godfather a book by
Mario Puzo and by the brilliant of film
versions of parts 1 & 2 of The Godfather
by Francis Ford Coppola these are major
contributions to the popular arts
however the you know just shows like The
Sopranos or the internal use of
italian-american people of archetypes of
buffoons I think this is just appalling
and that's an issue that I've I'm
getting quite militant about
Steubenville Ohio good morning morning I
have an almost sinking feeling in my gut
about the this country's disconnect with
the military
remember between Korea and Vietnam I
remember neighbors and relatives who due
to the draft had to serve for example
during the Gulf War and I was in the
National Guard at the time I personally
did not know of a soul who was
physically in the Gulf and a note on
ROTC in the early sixties I attended
Indiana University and the
best of my recollection although all
male freshmen and sophomores had to be
an ROTC thanks that's very interesting
indeed I can't imagine that being
imposed today that probably a revolt but
I do think I don't want to sound as like
a like a Cassandra or doomsayer but I do
think there's a kind of a weakening of
of will on the part of men of the
professional white upper-middle class I
you know I would fear for this country
where we something to have to go to war
there aren't enough able-bodied men to
draft that less goes on the moderate
line next on the conservative line is
from Pennsylvania is it pronounced
Macungie Macungie Macungie good morning
hi good morning miss Polly a pleasure to
speak with you I'm very honored I'm uh
I'm an avid listener of Rush Limbaugh
and he does frequently use you to make a
lot of points and a lot of comments that
you make and besides that I think he
likes you quite quite a bit as well
you I find you in a different position
than most feminists today when I see
Gloria Steinem or cats
patty Ireland or whatever her name is I
see you do you find yourself at odds
with these women the conservative
approach to feminism that I am in touch
with well actually my philosophies
libertarianism rather than conservatism
I feel that that government has a proper
place in the public sphere but that a
private life isn't as a zone of privacy
that should be protected from government
intrusion I've worked these issues out
in detail in my various writings I am a
dissident feminist III I leaned toward
the progressive side but I was one of
those one of the forces in the early
1990s that that broke down the
incestuous insularity of the feminist
establishment and demonstrated that
figures like Gloria Steinem
did not speak for all women and in fact
not even speak for all feminists but now
the young women of the 1990s the new
kind of feminism is a much more tolerant
and relaxed and much more open to
questions of beauty and and in those I
think there's starting to be a cessation
of male bashing that I and other figures
like Christina Hoff Sommers
what were assailing for for so many
years another article that caught your
attention was in the New York Times this
morning it's a television review Diana
Rigg as a detective armed with
one-liners on mystery on PBS Diana Rigg
is such an incredibly important figure
from me from the the great series of the
1960s the Avengers where she and her her
smart and lucid manner of a vocal
delivery enter her physicality with her
karate moves and so on this is a she's
an image which predated feminism I think
Diana Regan hurt in her kind of
cordiality toward men on that on that
program showed that it's possible for
strong women to to to live in harmony
with men now the reason I marked it is
that she is such a forceful figure in
the Performing Arts in Great Britain I
am very worried about the low quality of
our American popular culture at the
present moment as a 60s person I'm a
huge fan of pop but the the the lack of
technical expertise the decline in just
basic skills of of situation comedy
production or a filmmaking and the end
the kind of weaselly whiny figures like
I'm sorry to say Costa Flockhart as Ally
McBeal it distresses me diana rigg is a
worthy role model for the new feminists
in my book on that I wrote on Alfred
Hitchcock's the birds for the British
Film Institute I've tried to demonstrate
the incredible quality of a filmmaking
during the Hollywood studio era that
Hitchcock himself benefited from that
the the just the the quality of
photography of editing the kinds of
films you can hardly bear to watch a
film anymore coming out of Hollywood
clumsily edited it goes on forever
there's no sense of character or script
there's nothing for the eye to look at
so I was another thing I want to inspire
is young filmmakers to stop looking at
the film that was just made five years
ago but to go back in and and study the
great corpus of film is now available to
us thanks to TV TV with the AMC channel
and the trinamool channel provides the
the mass audience with examples of high
popular art making that should inspire
us so diana rigg is to me a symbol of
someone who has moved freely from the
world of shakespeare and serious drama
into that of popular culture and we need
much more of that I think in
contemporary Hollywood on the liberal
line and Arbor Michigan you're on with
Camille Polly ah good morning yes your
previous guest
comment was made about the decline of
enlistees in the military and also the
number of people in the military who are
not realistic and I want to ask your
present guests opinion about the fact
that one segment of the population has
been discouraged from a listing in the
military and those are the gays and
lesbians there is a book was a book
written called conduct unbecoming
written quite a few years ago about the
returning veterans from Vietnam many of
whom are so-called straight who relieve
their sexual tensions with each other
but when they got back resumed their
normal life as so-called straight people
whereas the gays were squeezed out and
they want to serve their country country
too and I'd like to have your guests
opinion about that well I'm gay myself
my position is that gays and lesbians
should be able to serve with honor in
the military but but the military has a
legitimate issue and in questioning the
the issues of the Solidarity of the core
and the kind of intimacy physical
intimacy that that young men and young
women have in basic training or in the
field where they may have doesn't sleep
all heaped up inside of a pup tent I
think that there are real technical
problems with was enforcing tolerance
for for gays and lesbians in the
military but I think that President
Clinton if he had been responsible would
have when he took office have said
instead of the way he did it which was
incredibly inflammatory and and stupid
and and created our presence untenable
situation of you know oh right now was
an increase actually in expulsion from
the military he should have said I as
president have the power to sign an
executive order on this issue however I
want to know in detail what are the
potential practical problems in allowing
gays and lesbians and serve openly in
the military and I appoint this
commission okay most of the import
civilian and military to report to me in
six months and then I don't promise that
I'm going to take the judgment of of the
of the Committee of the Commission I'm
going to take it under advisement and
then I will issue an executive order
that's the way it should have been done
we need a real airing of the practical
problems and and in the gay activist
groups in denying there are any problems
here okay have have have been equally I
think short-sighted little less than
twenty minutes with Camille Talia next
calls Culver City California good
morning good morning first let me start
off and by saying that I really enjoy
listening to your guests and your guests
and her really unique insight into
things I'm calling about an AP story
coming from Chicago on Tuesday November
9th it's Chicago school ends rifle
reprogram and it starts off in the wake
of the recent school shootings the
chicago public school system will drop
rifle retraining and competition offered
as part of the junior Reserve Officers
Training Corps program we don't want to
send a contradictory message in the
school by on the one hand discouraging
the use of firearms and being tough on
violence and then on the other
marksmanship curriculum public schools
chief Paul Vallas said on Monday and I
would like to ask what sort of a
contradictory message are we sending
when we encourage these kids to continue
with their military training which is
all about the use of arms all about the
use of force and then we say all guns
are bad and I would like to suggest that
it is the instructors here who are
confused they don't understand that
sometimes that guns are bad and
sometimes when they're used to resist
aggression when they're used in defense
they're very virtuous thank you
California very well put oh I I think
that's a deplorable dropping rifle
reprograms that would allow a young man
interested in guns and learn how to be
or in women interested in guns to learn
how to use them I think we need more
such programs just I think that we need
more encouragement to young men of the
kind that that shot up you know the high
school in Columbine come on has got a
little tune Colorado to join the
military I think there was a time when
young men had options available to them
they could go on to get on a freighter
and go around the world they could join
the army and satisfy their spirit of
adventure and instead we're caging young
men at the other hormonal peak in the
classroom treating them like like penned
animals giving them this bin now
education when I point the fact I say
okay we every every high school should
have programs of showing the correct and
disciplined use of firearms on the
conservative line Boise good morning
good morning good morning them
especially that's quite an honor I would
speak to you thank you I wanted to ask
two very different questions of you
number one if you saw the movie Saving
Private Ryan what you thought of it and
also why do you think Hillary is running
for Senate well I think I'm very happy
that Hollywood at last is starting to
treat the questions of war of adventure
in my lecture last night for the
Hirshhorn Museum here I showed some
military paintings that
huge impact on me I think that the the
end result of Saving Private Ryan will
be excellent and educating young people
about the the enormous sacrifices made
by by my parents generation during World
War two however I thought that there was
an excessive sensationalism and in the
very beginning the way the the violence
I think might have been even off-putting
for many people driven them from the
theater I think violence should be used
as the kind of climax to a narrative and
then and that in an opening Prelude and
secondly Hilary well I have been writing
on Hillary for four years now I was a
great admirer of her when she and when
she entered the White House with with
her husband and after the first
inauguration but slowly year by year I
have become progressively disillusioned
I think I now really I find her oddly
manipulative I am afraid I find my
writing some salon magazine have
chronicled a lot of this I think she's
never shown she can run anything now
this is a woman unlike let's say
Elizabeth Dole or Diane Feinstein or
christine Todd Whitman has never been
successful at anything she has done not
even I said in salon recently running
her dysfunctional family in their
decades-long squash in government
housing Carrollton at Georgia
good morning yes I'd like to speak to
this lady on two subjects military and
school so she's a teacher
maybe she she seems like tough person
who will held a backbone to speak up and
speak the truth
I'm retired master sword he's seven I
the Marine Corps I retired several years
ago in the military the biggest problem
we had was not we could promote on the
basis of ability and earn promotion we
had to promote on the basis of color of
skin or sexual you didn't have to earn
you rank you were promoted because of
what sex you were or what color you were
when I retired I retired basically
because of that reason the Marine Corps
wasn't men earning their way anymore
there they were politics involved and
you didn't earn your way I have a
granddaughter
as was fixing to start school this year
so I had heard how bad the school
systems were so I went back to the
school I graduated from Mount Zion
Georgia and I visited several other
schools with permission of school board
I found that there is no discipline in
schools anymore no children treat those
teachers like dogs Thank You Georgia
very much yes well the two issues there
I think the book is go out on how quotas
have been used in in promotion and
hiring in both the military and in
academia and every level of corporate
America now for the last 30 years there
are great benefits from that in in in
giving african-americans and women
greater visibility as as leaders but
unfortunately there is a backlash as a
as a consequence I don't think that the
past injustice can be remedied by a new
acts of injustice that treat white men
as if they now are you know our pariahs
or Untouchables so I think we're going
to pay the price of that in the long run
and the other issue is the question of
discipline in the classroom I completely
agree with this my father when went to
school at a time when he would often
describe the principal was would be seen
in the schoolyard as marching music
would be played marching the kids out
onto the sidewalk and the principal be
standing there with a truncheon his hand
beating and beating it into his palm and
keeping all the the very rough ethnic
Italian kids in line there was always
this kind of explosive power in
working-class use today there has been a
real retreat from any kind of will to to
enforce order in the classroom is
assumed that again that the that the the
classroom should be a place that's
almost like a kind of Club Med or a kind
of extension of the of the family den
instead of a place where education is
done I favor expulsion I've been on the
record about this for a long time when
you have students who are disorderly
ex-spouse
expel them for the benefit of the
economically underprivileged and
disadvantaged kids who want to learn so
we have stolen stolen the education of
of the obedient children in order to
privilege thugs and they expel them and
the problems on the streets let the
problem be on the streets the schools
should not be laboratories for social
engineering
edgert Seville New York good morning
good morning hi Camille hi
one of the reasons I like you is because
I can call you a babe without you being
offended I don't know if I'm a babe at
this point about midlife one of the
things I find particularly ironic is the
reason the woman's movement at least one
of the reasons of women's movement kind
of got its genesis was from people like
Bill Clinton the misogynist the woman
abuser and I would like to ask you
specifically and you know you are very
directed I really really hope that you
can answer this
you noticed obviously and you saw the
things regarding do I need a Broderick
now she was never really given a fair
airing by the media I would like to ask
you personally do you think that Bill
Clinton raped this woman and please be
direct and don't give me a Camille Polly
answer if you would okay two things
number one I have to say as a feminist
that for me the women's movement is one
of the great progressive movements of
the last 200 years that it's parallel to
abolitionism the movement to abolish
slavery as well as the end of child
labor which used to be just an ordinary
part of everyday life but all movements
do go astray and need a kind of
correction so I totally uphold the the
great principles of equality that are at
the heart of feminism at the same time
as I can I can fiercely criticized
feminist leaders when I think they
deserve it
but in regard to the Clinton case I feel
that the liberal media couldn't get away
with a lot of things I think Monica was
only the tip of the iceberg the idea
that this was one mistake is of course
absurd I think Hillary Clinton herself
deserves a lot of blame for her enabling
her of her husband in in a kind of
polarized view of women that is for
Hillary there is the there are the good
women the admirable women women of the
white upper-middle class who have gone
to law school and carry an attache case
and then there are the these sort of the
prostitute class the the [ __ ] the
bimbos the the men of Hillary's class
can can use them and then abuse them
destroy the reputation afterwards I
think that Hillary's behavior as well as
Clinton's and in sexual matters has been
deplorable utterly deplorable I regard
to the Broderick case however I must say
I don't know what happened there but I I
think for me it's very parallel to the
Anita Hill case I was the only feminist
was out there from week one saying that
Anita Hill was no feminist heroine I
thought what was done to Clarence Thomas
was up hauling it was a fascist exercise
dragging incidents from ten years
earlier that that I'm not doing a little
more than then perhaps slightly
inappropriate jokes told at in the at
lunch and the government cafeteria got
Clarence Thomas to all evidence never
laid a hand on it Anita Hill therefore
by the same logic I would say that the
wanita Broderick case occurred
unfortunately way too much in the past
to be used as any kind of evidence now
as someone doesn't make Clinton unfit
for office that we have a kind of
he-said she-said situation if the
assault occurred at Clinton dangers are
punished for Ford dirt during you know
within the statute of limitations but I
I have to say that a Juanita Broderick
story has flaws in it for me as a
feminist there is she hardly had met the
governor once called him at his
invitation she consented to meet with
him in her motel room this is a married
woman could did she was she honestly
surprised if Clinton and his though
fishness lunged at her assumed that this
intimacy was indeed a kind of consent to
it took contact I don't excuse his
behavior but again I think it occurred
so much in the past that we shouldn't be
over focusing on that last call on the
conservative line next call is
the moderate line is from Margate
Florida good morning good morning I have
two comments and then a question my son
is a Marine officer and he serves out a
love of country and sense of duty
I hope our political leadership never
takes that away from him and the other
communist many civilians role the
military and the extremists and the NRA
all in one ball and that results in a
negative opinion I think we're still
haunted by the term baby killers from
the Vietnam War and that affects our
military my question is I can see the
day where we'll reinstate the draft and
I'm curious where does that leave women
I'll hang up and listen to your answer
thank you well two things were there I
think that the the people who are the
ward Smiths who who write for the media
who belong to the professional class
many whom are clustered in the
northeastern corridor tend to not
understand at all of the the most
Americans interest in weapons the use of
weapons for for hunting that would be
simply a part of the culture of the
south or of the West I think there's a
real culture gap there and an arrogance
and also of ultimately provincialism on
the part of the media there is no harm
in weapons except when they are are used
by criminals that is the fact of matter
nevertheless I think there are too many
weapons right now in American Society of
the automatic variety that allow people
to shoot up their workplace without any
kind of a skill although that it's the
automatic weapons I think that are the
real danger in regard to women the draft
I my philosophy is that of an equity
feminist I think that that for all the
rights that women demand a society that
they must also take on a responsibility
I would favor drafting women I feel that
that military service should be should
be a duty and should be a privilege not
all feminists probably would agree with
that position and still to this day most
people are queasy about the idea of
women in combat despite the the presence
of women in armies around the world
including in Israel there we've have
actually very few examples of women used
in a true face-to-face combat situation
early on in your comments and talking
about the NEA you were said you were
looking forward to a renaissance in the
arts what role will government have if
any in that Renaissance I think it's
important that that every nation take
responsibility for preserving its
cultural heritage and for for creating a
climate where young artists can develop
I think that the NEA again just just
just destroyed its own prestige and the
way it handled things we certainly need
much more of funding for community arts
projects for arts lessons dance lessons
and and in training with musical
instruments but I think that that that
we should have that one of the points I
raised last night in my lecture for the
Hirshhorn Museum was that we need I
think national radio channels that have
that are exclusively devoted to the
education and about classical music jazz
which is the great art form produced by
America blues I think that kind thing a
National Film consortium that would that
would preserve mint condition or classic
films and distribute them after foot to
high schools and to colleges to make
sure that that all young people have
exposure to to the arts not only a fine
arts but but our pot our great popular
arts to Bucks County Pennsylvania good
morning Oh ma'am I'd like to address
your contempt for liberals contempt for
Limbaugh for a moment Mario Cuomo had an
open invitation that debate Limbaugh in
public whenever Limbaugh won of course
Lynn would never took him up on because
only performs in front of friendly
audiences Limbaugh is is a classic
example of the following what he said
was true but it wasn't a hard truth so
it was all a big lie
he will take one small aspect out of
something that happens and presented in
its worst possible light and then whole
run with it that way and my first
comment is you said that you were the
disillusion one of the reasons you were
disillusioned with Hillary is because
she's manipulative I find it interesting
that you aren't disillusioned with
Limbaugh because of how manipulative he
seems to be well first is a commentator
equivalent to a columnist in in a
newspaper or what he does is a pin
and he he improvises off the off the
day's news but I mean there's our having
six distortions on the left as well his
refusal to to debate Cuomo why should
Rush Limbaugh have to debate anyone it
has to be remembered that that his
Limbaugh's prominence has come from his
connection with a mass audience that he
began as a very obscure radio announcer
and slowly built this audience I first
heard about him from my Italian
relatives in upstate New York they
weren't even sure how to spell his name
they thought it was Ross limbo they were
mentioning him and then then Limbaugh
began noticing my my work and began
mentioned talking about it particularly
my my critique of the feminist
establishment a phrase that you know
that I invented
I think Rush Limbaugh has done an
enormous amount actually to to help the
demands to analyze the day's news we
need Rush Limbaugh as a counterpoise for
heaven's sakes to the to the dominance
of the of the the print media still in
the major newspapers on the northeast by
by a liberal interest ie you could
hardly read the political news in the
New York Times anymore I earned first
the New York Post which is which is a
scandal that one must return to what
used to be considered a tabloid for the
real truth about what's happening before
you then get the kind of softened and
partial version of any event in The
Times as part of our American presidents
portrait series tonight on c-span of
eight o'clock is an interview we did
earlier with Lady Bird Johnson you
mentioned several times that your
connection to the 60s and she was
prominent in those years and as worth
looking forward to this interview with
her what are your recollections of Lady
Bird Johnson well I've always been
impressed with Texas women I think that
there is a real pioneer spirit still in
the way the the southern women and Texas
women presents themselves I think the
governor and Richards just had a kind of
has they'd used the word ballsy may I on
the air I'm not sure a kind of a
formidable combative quality at the same
time as the southern women or the Texas
women are able to doll themselves up in
a conventionally female way I think
women who aspire to political leadership
in America should just study the
precedence of
of the strong spoken Texas woman Camille
Polya professor and author thank you
very much thank you again that interview
with Lady Bird Johnson tonight here on
c-span at eight o'clock part of our
American president's life portrait
series we'll be back in a few minutes as
we continue to focus on military pay
Kevin Elyot Bloxom of the Defense
Department here to talk about military
pay our second segment on that subject
before that though some more scenes from
Arlington National Cemetery from
yesterday's preparations were underway
for today's commemoration of Veterans
Day